4 mois après les Porom du 7 octobre la
France rend demain un hommage national à
ses 42 enfants massacrés par les
djihadistes du Hamas enfin avidane
Valentin Karine Ruth Naomi Sigal Céline
ela et les autres 42 français parmi les
1200 civiles massacrés décapités brûlés
ces femmes violées puis tuées devant
leur famille leur corps profané et
exhibés comme des trophée je regrette
par ailleurs que les familles des
dizaines de soldats franco-israéliens
tombés en héros ne soient pas convien à
cet hommage mais je pense surtout au 136
otages détenus en ce moment dans les
djihadistes au bébfir 1 an et à tous ces
femme violé en permanence mais comme je
le craignais après la compassion la
sidération vient le temps des
accusations de l'inversion de la charge
et même de la nazification d'Israël au
Grand Cirque de la haie l'Afrique du Sud
régime corrompu criminogène place l'État
juif sur le banc des accusé dans un
simulacre de prosé qui déshonore la
justice internationale le monde doit
comprendre 80 ans après la Choa que le
peuple juif n'ira plus jamais à
l'abattoir sans réagir cette guerre a
été imposée à Israël c'est un acte de
justice et non de vengeance pendant ce
temps l'extrême gauche est Arafa pas un
mot pour les otages elle vient pour
soutenir l'agence de l'ONU impliqué
directement dans les porôes et donct il
faut définitivement cesser le
financement comble de l'indécence et de
la provocation ils seront là demain qui
imagine Bousquet Papon fauisson
participer à l'hommage annuel de la
rafle du veldive car c'est cela dont il
s'agit monsieur le Premier ministre je
suis le député de ces familles qui ont
écrit au au président de la République
elle ne veut pas des pores-parol des
porte-paroles du ramas demain la France
ne peut balayer leurs émotion et leur
colère oui l'indignité existe elle rôe
près de Marianne et il dépose ses
tumeurs de grâce qu'ils aient un sursaut
de décence et d'humanité envers les
victimes pour ne pas s'imposer à à
l'hommage pas aux invalide dans ce
temple républicain Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pourquoi les avoir invité
pourquoi ne pas dresser comme par le
passé pour d'autres un cordon sanitaire
avec les antisémites qui font l'apologie
du terrorisme et disent-il la haine du
Juif merci la parole est à Madame frisc
t porte-parole du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député permettez-moi de vous
répondre au nom du gouvernement il y a 4
mois le 7 octobre
2023 des vies ont été violemment arraché
par la folie terroriste le 7 octobre
2023 l'horreur surgissait à nouveau dans
le quotidien des israélien le 7 octobre
2023 commençait l'inéluctable souffrance
des familles des proches et des blessés
le 7 octobre 2023 une attaque terroriste
des plus barbares a été menée par le
Hamas contre l'État d'Israël contre des
Israéliens contre des Français contre
des Juifs monsieur le député par deà nos
divers politique il y a des moments qui
nous appellent collectivement à la
hauteur l'hommage national voulu par le
Président de la République fait partie
de ces moments demain nous devons nous
souvenir ensemble des noms et des
visages de celles et ceux qui ont été
arrachés par le à leur famille si le
protocole prévoit d'inviter tous les
responsables politiques chacun chacun
appréciera l'opportunité ou non de sa
présence puisque les familles se sont
exprimé je tiens ici une nouvelle
à dire que justifier le terrorisme c'est
accepter qu'il frappe à
nouveau je vous remercie madame la
ministre